An authorised league of party
candidate lists of the a N C.
And the newly formed Mkhondoa seizure party
is owed to one of the I
C's own officials.
Corrective action in terms of applicable
labour laws is underway
and the official
has been requested to make submission as to why
their contract of employment should not be terminated.
The two parties
are preparing to go head to head in the Electoral Court
over the use and name of Anconto Eccesare,
the NC's former armed military wing.
The I. C. Says it is in the hands of the court.
The matter between um
m. K, the N C.
And regarding the registration of the party,
we are in the hands of the courts.
We have said all that we needed to say
in terms of our filing er in the court.
Over 27.79 million voters,
the highest since the dawn of democracy,
are eligible to cast their votes.
The role has further increased
in the rate of representation in the 18 to 39 age group,
which accounts for 11.7 million voters.
In addition,
the well entrenched trend of more women voters
on the roll continues.
With all these developments,
the official opposition party has written to the west
to monitor elections,
a move which may have been perceived as the opposition
costing doubts on the electoral system of South Africa.
Nonetheless, we are
alive to the fact that er,
excuse me, that er,
the letter by,
by the d a. Is directly to A er,
an executive in another country.
That's not how ordinarily the observation process works.
Often the observation works at the multilateral level,
such as at the er, a U level,
Cedric level,
er, Commonwealth level, and so on and so on and so on.